it's a giant geothermal Lagoon
essentially a misty lake of hot sea
water it's in a very unusual very
dramatic setting adjacent to a power
plant and surrounded by volcanoes and
old lava fields
this strange and steamy world of black
rock and bright blue water is Iceland's
most popular attraction it lures more
than 300 thousand people a year mostly
tourists but warm water is warm water
and even the locals get into the swim of
things the blue lagoon looks natural but
it was formed by this geothermal power
plant the plant takes superheated water
out of the ground and uses it to make
energy when they originally pumped it
back out into the lava fields the water
formed a lagoon salt content according
to Grenier salmon s'en it's been a mecca
for people looking to soak away their
tension ever since after a strong
working week lands the best thing you
could do is go into water and relax a
bit it's it's great it's absolutely
great and afterwards your skin feels
soft and you feel great and relaxed and
I think of people you know they really
really are impressed the average
temperature in the lagoon is about 100
degrees Fahrenheit as you swim out
toward the center though where the main
steam vent is you can feel it getting
hotter
there's blue-green algae in the water
and white silica mud on the bottom which
is how the lagoon gets its soft milky
aquamarine color but even more unique
they say the water and the mud have
curative healing powers especially for
people with skin ailments like psoriasis
it looks funny but a lot of the bathers
go over to one corner and slather the
wet chalky sediment all over their
bodies though Iceland may not be thought
of as a hot spot for tourists the Blue
Lagoon may yet change some minds